we got a call early in the morning an
invitation to join a convoy on a mission
that no one would reveal our destination
was a prison which sits in a heap on the
banks of the Nile
it's where the political prisoners are
kept and it's where the generals who run
this country put Sudan's longtime
dictator Omar al-bashir when they
toppled him nine weeks ago now they're
going to try him prosecution of Omar
al-bashir is the one thing that all
people in this country agree on and
that's why we're here this is what the
military want us to see
we were the only foreign journalists at
Coburg prison and we watched as
al-bashir bad in national dress make his
way through a waiting vehicle was his
first public appearance
tomboy reformed and sped to the state
prosecutor's office where the 75 year
old was due for questioning on charges
of corruption and possession of foreign
currency however the former tyrant seen
here in January will not be sent to the
International Criminal Court
he's wanted on multiple counts including
genocide for the deaths of hundreds of
thousands in the province of Darfur but
the generals say he stained justice it
seems we'll be done in Sudan although
some officials weren't keen on us
still the ruling generals think the
prosecution of al-bashir
is the best way
are you surprised to be here mr.
al-bashir
he was only in there for about ten
minutes giving a statement to the
country's prosecution authorities we
think he's going straight back to jail
what a very gratifying scene
pro-democracy activists accused the
military of trying to distract the
public after dozens of protesters were
shot but a leading General in the ruling
council told Sky News they were
troublemakers don't believe a Bashir
dominated this country for decades but
the struggle for power has moved on and
his future will be decided by the winner
John sparks Sky News cartoon